what do
we have here
i am actually really excited about this
i already know what's inside of here it
is the new microsoft surface duo 2. i
did get a little bit of hands-on time at
the microsoft lounge but now oh my
goodness i get to have all of the
hands-on time that i want because it is
here in the studio i'm so excited i even
brought out the big knife today
alright this is so sharp i should not
have something like this in my in my
possession
oh boy oh boy here it is oh can't wait
to open this up we also have a couple
other little things here
[Music]
oh look at you
oh this has a nice it's a heavy feel
let's put this cover on
look at that
um
[Music]
all right we got a sim card ejector
nice
oh
usb cable look at that love to see it i
am going to
turn this on and get it all set up and
then we're going to go out and do some
testing i cannot wait to test out these
new cameras obviously the first service
duo was not a device that you would want
to be making any type of content on it
definitely did not have this advanced of
a camera system and of course i don't
think that this is going to be one of
the highest quality camera systems on
any smartphones right now but the fact
that they do have this three camera
system plus the inside front-facing i
guess this would be kind of front-facing
it really depends how you have it
because like right now is this the front
is this the back hard to say but having
this dual screen device it's so much
more different than like the samsung
devices where they're the foldables and
the flippables flippables this is more
like having dual monitors as opposed to
like a laptop that folds if that doesn't
make any sense i'm not even sure what
i'm saying let's take off this last
sticker pop in the sim card set it up
and start testing
[Music]
this is the magnetic charging case that
allows you to charge your
stylus just like so it's also kind of
crazy because this is a phone but it
doesn't feel like a phone it feels like
so much more because it is so much more
than a phone i mean we have dual screens
this feels like a very small little tiny
laptop i really like the notification
panel here on the hinge it's kind of
cool because you'll be able to see the
time you'll be able to see if you have a
bunch of notifications like text
messages and that little light right
there that lets you give a phone call
the previous version was really
difficult because you didn't actually
know what was happening inside of here
so even just this tiny small little
notification has made such a huge
difference in using this let's take some
photos i want to test out this camera
[Music]
okay the portrait mode actually
did a pretty good job that was the
front-facing portrait that's nice
whoa wide angle super wide
like this is kind of cool
over here on this side are all the
photos that i've taken
and i still have the camera app open on
the other side oh we have panorama too
there we go
[Music]
oh man i'm loving this new surface 2 duo
surface 2 surface 202 2 is 2 so it's duo
2.
while other foldables and flippables are
still technically one display this
actually brings you two separate screens
for running various apps side by side
you can drag and drop between screens
and apps that support this you can
create customized combos with app groups
and you can even take notes with the new
surface slim pen so the app groups are
actually kind of cool so you can put
various things inside of little folders
so this is my app group we have edge and
onenote and when i click that it'll open
up both of those things at the same time
so you can set up different ones for
like social media so if i would have
tiktok and let's see instagram open i
can just make this little
app group right here
so
i can open up both tick tock
and instagram
at the same time like this is a freaking
dream come true
just but
just what my attention span needs it
also now has 5g which is very exciting
you can record 4k video up to 60 frames
a second and there's also slow-mo at 120
or 240 at 1080p now it is extremely thin
at 5.5 millimeters with a 5.8 inch
touchscreen that spans 8.3 when they are
both open they've made the surface duo
more durable and it's available in two
colors the signature glacier white like
the previous version and this new
obsidian finish it gets very very smudgy
but i have been keeping on this magnetic
slim pen
charger cover it's actually quite nice
so because of the camera bump
it doesn't lay as flat
as the old version used to but it
doesn't wiggle around a lot kind of like
the iphone does so when you put the
iphone down it's kind of like off-center
a little bit but this it's just
like it doesn't move it just doesn't lay
flat so this was just a first look at
the new surface duo 2 i really love it
this is one of my favorite devices of
last year i'm really glad that they did
decide to make a second version of this
because it really is awesome a lot of
the flaws that were in the first version
they have thankfully fixed if you guys
are new here be sure to subscribe so
you'll be alerted when i post new videos
leave me some comments below and i'll
see you guys in the next video
[Music]
you